Thank you to dollar shave club for sponsoring this video,
go to dollar shave club.com forward slash biographics to get your shaver start
us out, but just $5 more unlimited that's.
Well, many gangsters have monuments built in their honor. However,
if you were to travel to the Flamingo hotel in Las Vegas,
you would find one dedicated to Bugsy Siegel.
Siegel was a prominent member of the Jewish bald throughout the 1930s and 1940s.
He was an ally of fellow Jewish gangster mayor landscape,
and together they established close ties to the New York mafia governed by the
commission, their criminal organizations,
and several others were often grouped together as a loose Confederation,
which the media dubbed the national crime syndicate.
Many of the most violent actions over this Indigo,
particularly mob hits often carried out by a ruthless group,
which had been co-founded by Bugsy Siegel.
The infamous murder incorporated Siegel ones admitted to a real estate
developers that he killed over a dozen men.
He had been involved in bootlegging during prohibition, then in gambling,
extortion and prostitution, after it was repealed.
And he had the legacy by which he is primarily remembered today has nothing to
do with any of that. He is regarded as a smart businessman,
even as a visionary by some who looked at a desert wasteland and saw the
potential to turn it into one of the biggest gambling destinations in the world.
Even today, Bugsy Siegel is often called the man who invented Las Vegas.
Although as we'll soon, find out this name is not accurate,
but even so Bugsy Siegel was undoubtedly.
One of America's most notorious mobsters and has played a huge role in the
history of sin.
City.
Benjamin Siegel was born on February the 28th, 1906 in Brooklyn,
New York to max and Jenny Siegel,
a pair of poor Jewish immigrants who came to America from Galicia,
a region of the Austro-Hungarian empire,
which is now part of Ukraine is nickname of Bugsy or bugs came later during his
mobster years. But for the sake of consistency,
we're going to call him up from the beginning.
Allegedly other gangsters came up with this in reference to his quick and
violent temper, because he was as crazy as a bedbug Siegel. However,
hated the nickname likely because the mention of bedbugs reminded him of his
poor childhood raised in squalor.
And as most people who called him Bugsy to his face,
risked finding out exactly how he earned the Monica. I'm surprisingly young.
Ben wanted to escape his life of poverty as soon as possible.
And like many other teenagers who resided in the poor,
violent neighborhoods of Brooklyn,
he saw crime as the quickest way of accomplishing his goal.
By the time he was around 14 years old Bugsy already had a gang of hoodlums and
even worked his first extortion racket. He would go up to push cough pedal.
As you sold various trinkets out of that constant demands payment in exchange
for his protection services. If they refused,
he would douse that concent kerosene and threatened to light the whole thing on
fire. It was around this time that Siegel started associating with other future
notable mobsters. One of the guys in his gang was most segway.
Who'd go on to become an important lieutenants in the Jewish Marvins would
continue to look after the bulbs interests in Las Vegas off to Siegel's death.
The bugs, his criminal career took a significant turn in 1918.
When he met another tough Jewish thug named male landscape,
the exact story of how the two became friends,
it's never been established with certainty,
but the popular version says that landscape saved Siegel's life.
During a craps game,
as landscape was coming home from school one day he's or a bunch of other people
playing dice on a street corner with Siegel among them,
I fight broke out and someone knocked Bugsy to the grounds and a pistol fell out
of his coat.
The other player picks up the gun aimed at Siegel and was getting ready to
shoot, but Bensley jumps in and knocks the other going over.
Right then the police whistles started ringing through the air.
So everybody ran for the Hills Siegel and landscape got away together and became
close friends. Soon afterwards, the two forms, the bugs and mare mob,
which would go on to become the powerful force in new York's lower East side
landscape was not known to be a particularly violent man and usually prefer to
delegate the dirty work.
So he was considered the brains of the operation while Siegel was the brawn.
Initially the members of the mob United together to ensure a strong Jewish
criminal front against the rise of Italian and Irish gangs. However,
the landscape was not one to pass up good business opportunities.
So his outfit soon started having dealings with Italian gangs,
particularly that sort of an up and coming mobster named Charles lucky
Luciano.
Once prohibition came in and the bugs and man mob started making a lot of money
from bootlegging.
In addition to the traditional gambling car theft robbery and extortion rackets,
the gang certainly did not shy away from murder either and developed a
particularly ruthless and violent reputation. And in fact,
the bugs and ma'am bulbs don't need to become the go-to source for murder,
for hire services.
And as such came to be regarded as the precursor to murder Inc.
Bugsy Siegel.
I was rising through the ranks of America's criminal underground during a period
marked by tamale valance and shifting allegiances.
There were lots of tough disputes, which led to a lot of bloodshed,
which in turn created unwanted attention from the police and the media,
and that didn't help anyone to try and resolve this prominent criminal figures
from all over the country,
gathered in one place to see if they could work things out.
The Atlantic city conference held between may the 13th and the 16th, 1929,
and hosted by Advantix city, political boss, enact Nikki Johnson.
The man who served as the basis for Nikki Thompson,
the main character from boardwalk empire.
This was considered the first crime summit to take place in the United States.
The first of only a handful that we know about every one of importance was in
attendance. That was the Chicago outfit headed by Al Capone,
the Jewish mob from Philly,
the purple gang from Detroit representatives from Kansas city,
Boston Cleveland's new Orleans unsurprisingly New York was the best represented
region, not only where the lieutenants from all of the mafia families,
but also the Irish mob, the New Jersey mob and the gang led by Dutch Schultz.
Male landscape was one of the men who organized the whole thing.
So of course he was there and he was accompanied by Bugsy.
Siegel is represents their own bugs and may have mob.
The general idea of being promoted at the conference was the gang violence was
bad for business for everyone,
but the attention mainly focused on two ongoing disputes.
The first was one in Chicago.
The infamous St Valentine's day massacre had only occurred a few months prior,
and it brought more attention to organized crime than any previous events.
There's part Al Capone said that he was willing to live and let live.
Although of course,
this was after he had already severely crippled his rival organization that was
led by bugs Morin.
The fact that nobody from Morin's outfit even attended the conference was very
indicative of the current power dynamic in Chicago,
suggesting that everyone realized that the city was Capones and any further
serious tough disputes were unlikely.
The same could not be said for New York city back then there were still the boss
of all bosses who claimed dominion over all other mafia, families of the city.
That was the way that it was done in the old country,
but the time they were changing,
those who attended the conference understood that the old ways could not work
forever. And as long as one man would rule alone at the top,
there would always be another one gun in for his head.
This is in fact exactly what was going on New York at the time two men were
vying for the position of boss of all bosses.
One was [inaudible] known as Joe,
the boss and the other was Salvatore Maranzano.
And it was a conflict known as the customer, easy war,
both miss Syria and Maranzano were considered mustache Petes,
old school mobsters from Sicily who weren't interested in changes.
Unsurprisingly, neither one attended the conference in Atlantic city,
but the lieutenants did and they included men like lucky, new China,
Frank Costello, Colorado Gambino, and Vieta Genevese.
They were considered young Turks.
It represented the new guards looking to reform the criminal hierarchy.
The conclusion at the end of the conference was that the mustache Petes of the
world had to die out before any significant change could happen.
It started with miss Syria, Joe, the boss was gunned down on April the 15th,
1931 betrayed by his own lieutenants, lucky to China,
according to the common story for men short, miss Syria,
as he was leaving a restaurants and among them was Bugsy Siegel, who,
by this point, it's often worked as a hired gunman for Luciano.
Some historians dispute this fashion of events,
but we cannot say with certainty either way.
We also can't positively say that Siegel took part in the assassination of
Salvatore Maranzano, which occurred only a few months later,
but he has been connected to that murder as well.
Now that both Syria and Erin's were dead as a new China and his allies forms the
commission, the governing body of the American mafia,
which oversaw all of its criminal activities and was ruled by a board of
directors instead of a single man,
seven crime families originally had a seat on the board,
the five from New York plus Capone's Chicago outfit and to the Buffalo crime
family with everyone else being represented by one of the seven guys like Matt
Lansky and Bugsy Siegel could not be a part of the official hierarchy
established by the commission because they were not Italian,
but they still held powerful positions as associates,
especially given that close association.
So lucky new Chano who served as the commission's first chairman.
I mean say what you want about these mob guys,
but they were often pretty well put together.
And if you want to look like a million bucks,
then dollar shave club has got you covered for all of your grooming needs,
shower, oral care deodorant sands, of course, and most important bleeds shaving.
Now I don't shave my beard, but I do shave my head.
And that experience has become so much better since switching to dollar shave
club and using the high quality blades dollar shave club sent me the ultimate
shave starter set, razor and blades. Of course,
this is the a six bladed executive version feeling very
executive. And then there's this kit that comes with it. There's the prep scrub.
Um, basically you put this on before then.
There's the shave butter which you use during,
and then there's the post saved you,
which you used afterwards on the post-sale do you,
because I got a little dry upstairs after I shaved.
What's it like to slap some of that post tape?
Do you want to keep setting nice and hydrated up there?
So visit dollar shave club.com forward slash biographics and you'll get this
ultimate shave starter set for only $5.
You can also round out your grooming routine by adding any of their other high
quality products. And after that,
the restock box will ship full-sized products at the regular price that's dollar
shave club, check it out. There's also a link below and let's get back.
[Inaudible].
With the formation of this new national crimes indicates the bugs. A man,
Bob disbanded,
as both men assumed various positions within this new larger organization.
Mayor Lansky worked as one of Luciano's closest associates and nuns of the
nickname of the mobs accountant.
Does he set up many profitable businesses for the mafia with prohibition on the
way out, Bugsy also finds new avenues of revenue, but throughout the 1930s,
his main occupation was still acting as a gunman.
Whenever someone was making trouble for Lansky or Chano,
he managed to evade legal troubles as except for one arrest for illegal gambling
in 1932,
which resulted in a small fine that Siegel paid on the spot from a thick roll of
bills. This ended up being the only conviction in his entire criminal career,
but just because he was saved from the law,
did not mean that nobody was out to get him even with powerful backing Siegel
still made a lot of murderers enemies.
And in the late 1930s landscape decided that New York was becoming too dangerous
for him.
So he sent Segal to the West coast to help set up a new syndicate racket that in
1937, Bugsy Siegel arrived in Los Angeles.
There he met the boss of the Los Angeles crime family, Jack Dragnet,
and the two forms, a fractious relationship, which is still unclear today.
Siegel and drag now have often been described as bitter rivals who had to work
together,
dragging up a man once referred to as the Capone of Los Angeles was now forced
to take a subservient role to the new guy from New York,
because Siegel had the support of the commission. If this was indeed the case,
it would be easy to see how Dragnet would grow to resent seagull.
But historians have argued that the rivalry between the two has been exaggerated
and that they cooperated enough to make a lot of money together.
One person Dragnet definitely did not like was Mickey Cohen.
Another gangster from New York who had been sent by landscape to help out Segal
Cohen started off as a simple body yard and Rose through the ranks with his new
detail in Los Angeles, being his big promotion, indeed ones,
Bugsy Siegel was dead Dragnet trying to take out Cohen's several times and
failed with Mikiko and eventually becoming the most powerful mobster in
Hollywood back to boxy,
he took an immediate liking to the glitz and glamor of Tinseltown and soon
became a regular as all the lavish Hollywood parties.
He had an introduction through a childhood friend act to George raft and Siegel
was soon rubbing elbows with movie stars, musicians, directors,
and big time studio executives. At this time,
he also began an affair with a would be actress named Virginia Hill,
which would last on and off until his death.
This period in bug's life contained some of his more colorful adventures.
For example, in 1938, he believed he came to possess a genuine treasure maps.
So he chartered a sailboat, smuggled, some dynamize and vomited,
a bunch of Hollywood friends and went off sailings to an Island off the coast of
Costa Rica. A few days of digging and explosions followed,
but there was no trash to be found.
And even craziest story happens the following year when seagull trying to sell
explosives to Benito Mussolini,
this unlikely business opportunity came courtesy of one of Siegel's place,
friends in Hollywood, or at JRS named counters,
Dorothy to Frasso who owns a lavish filler in Italy.
And it was an acquaintance of the dictator through her husband Bugsy and Dorothy
had invested in a new type of explosive gold atomized.
And she reasoned that muscly would make the perfect bar for us.
Siegel took a trip to Italy in 1939,
but the new venture turned out to be a Dada's muscly and he was unimpressed with
the capabilities. And Artemide on that occasion.
Bugsy allegedly also met hunting and gathering and disliked him so much that he
wanted to shoot him. Bus was persuaded otherwise by the counts, as,
as implausible as this whole story sounds,
there is actually quite a lot of evidence to support the idea that Bugsy Siegel
tried to sell out to Mike Dima. Salini the bond about Gehring however,
is mostly just hearsay. These distractions made for entertaining stories,
but for the most part,
Bugsy stuck to what he was best at while he was in Los Angeles and he ran
gambling operations, narcotics, prostitution rings, and extortion rackets.
He still occasionally served as a gunman and in 1940,
he was charged with the murder of fellow mobster, Harry Greenberg,
AKA big greeny.
Although this became the most serious crime that Siegel was ever charged with,
ultimately he was not convicted due to insufficient evidence.
Siegel was acquitted of Greenberg's murder.
All the media attention surrounding his trial made Hollywood stars a bit more
apprehensive about associating with the mobster power.
This turned into the perfect opportunity for Siegel to look into a new business
venture elsewhere. Gambling has always been a good moneymaker for him,
and he went down to Nevada to acquire an interest in a racing publication called
Trans-America.
Why Siegel became increasingly engrossed with the idea of setting up a shop in
Las Vegas and opening a luxury gambling result for the rich and famous.
He saw firsthand that such establishments were doing very well because contrary
to popular belief Siegel's hotel was not the first of its kind on the last Vegas
strip, which back then was simply called highway 91. That's on,
I belong to El Rancho Vegas, which opens in 1941,
initially SQL purchase the El Cortez hotel and casino in 1945 for
$600,000.
The current newly renovated Cortez even has a restaurant called seagulls in 1941
in honor of its notorious. One time owner.
However Siegel found it problematic operating this hotel because local officials
weren't too happy about working with a mobster. Instead,
Bugsy looked for something outside of that purview since strictly speaking,
the Vegas strip technically only includes the part of the Boulevard,
which is outside city limits Siegel found exactly what he was looking for in the
form of the Flamingo hotel being built outside Vegas by Billy Wilkerson,
the Los Angeles nightclub owner and founder of the Hollywood reporter Wilkerson
ran out of money for the project and needed a new funding.
So he accepted Bugsy Siegel is a partner,
whether or not he has an actual say in the matter is I'm certain, but well,
cause then eventually sold all the stakes in the hotel before it was finished.
The Flamingo was now owned by the mob Siegel,
took over the building project and began acting his vision of a luxury resort.
Most of the other Las Vegas hotels were all done in a dude ranch style,
but this was not good enough for Bugsy who wanted something.
Classier his hotel would have modern deco with a golf course and tennis courts
and everybody would dress in formal wear,
including the staff who would wear tuxedos.
He convinced mayor Lansky and other high ranking mobsters that construction
would cost between 1.2 and $1.5 million.
But this was nowhere near the Mark. By the time the hotel was actually finished,
construction costs had sought to over $6 million.
Part of this was due to Siegel's poor management and financial skills positive.
It was due to contract as taking advantage of his inexperience and Cunningham by
charging double for the materials. Part of it may also have been due to Siegel,
skimming off the top to pay for his own luxurious lifestyle.
The Flamingo hotel had its grand opening on December the 26th, 1946.
And it was a total disaster for starters, the casino was open,
but the actual hotel was still under construction.
Siegel was hoping to draw in a lot of the Hollywood crowns, Ghana,
extra attention. He had the band's leader. Xavia Q GAT to provide music well,
Jimmy Durante headline, the night's entertainment.
Some of his Hollywood powers like George raft and Sony,
Tufts were in attendance, but most slabs were kept away by heavy downfall.
Most people who did venture inside the casino,
he seemed to have a hot hand because they won big with no rooms available.
They cashed out their winnings and went someplace else.
Within one week of opening, the Flamingo lost another $300,000.
This was really bad because Siegel had some knew that it was in hot water with a
syndicate due to his extreme overspending.
His only saving grace was that belief that he could make the Flamingo profitable
and return their investments.
But now it seems like that would not be the case with no other option.
Bugsy closed down the hotel two weeks after the grand opening and waited for
construction to finish. It was reopened on March the first, 1947.
This time renamed to the fabulous Flamingo.
It actually ended up turning a profit soon after,
but even that was not enough to save Siegel,
Bugsy Siegel.
He was a hot topic of discussion among the mob bosses of the date in late
December, 1946,
another crime summit was held just like the one in Atlantic city. Back in 1929.
This time it was held in Havana, Cuba.
So lucky Luciano could attend as he had been deported to Italy earlier that
year, the meeting itself took place on December.
The 22nd at the hotel did Nasional to Cuba and over 20 bosses were in attendance
among the subjects of discussion was the seagulls situation.
As mayor Lansky put it Siegel had gone away of a budget on building the Flamingo
after persuading, a lot of people to invest their money in it.
Plus everyone was pretty sure that he was also stealing as his girlfriend,
Virginia Hill made frequent trips to Switzerland.
That was also concerned that Bugsy was preparing to flee the country of things
done sideways. So ultimately it was decided that he had to go, however,
male landscapers waited everyone to wait until the Flamingo opened to see how
well it did. They agreed bots as we already discussed,
the opening went terribly even so out of a sense of loyalty.
If there is one time close friends landscape, trying to convince them again,
to wait a few more months, to see if Segal could turn it around.
But did he succeed on the night of June? The 20th of 1947,
Bugsy Siegel was sitting in the living room of the Beverly Hills mansion that
Virginia Hill reading the newspaper when he was shot multiple times with a 30
caliber rifle by an unknown gunman Siegel was hit four times,
three times in the head and twice in the chest,
a popular story says that one bullet has been in the eye and execution dubbed
the mode green special off to the character in the godfather who gets killed in
the same way, a character who by the way was based on Bugsy Siegel. However,
this wasn't exactly how it happened is the bullet did not actually hit Bugsy XY,
but the force of the impact did cause it to pop out.
So of course the big questions are who did it and why the most obvious answer is
that it was a mob hit due to the mismanagement of the casino.
Seagull made too many powerful enemies and landscape couldn't protect him.
Forever. Many people are convinced. This is what happens. And for them,
the only mystery is who pulled the trigger while this is more uncertain.
The name most commonly brought up is Frankie Cabo, a gunman for motor rink.
There are a couple of other theories though.
One says that the shooter was one of Virginia Hills brothers taking revenge for
the beatings that sequel gave his sister. Another idea involves a strange love.
Triangle consisting of mobster moves segway, his wife B and her lover,
moose Penza. And this story actually comes courtesy of B segue herself.
We mentioned most that way at the start of this video,
he was part of Siegel's teenage gang of criminals.
So the two of them went way back,
but that relationship soured heavily during the construction of the casino
sideway was that to oversee seagull,
spending something which Bugsy greatly resented.
Eventually he had had enough and wanted mood debt.
The latter found out about this and want his wife that something might happen to
him, to which she replied that she would ask me to protect him.
So according to be,
it was moose Panzer that night who gunned down Bugsy Siegel in order to protect
his love, his husband, some of Lansky's men,
including most segway took over the operations of the Flamingo.
The day after Siegel's death. As far as the mob was concerned,
it was business as usual and its involvement with the Vegas casinos lasted for
decades to come. And it became one of its most profitable dentures,
Bugsy Siegel.
Might've also been the man who invented Las Vegas as he is often called,
but his legacy remains unique in the annals of crime and in comparable to that
of any other gangster. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do smash that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe. Don't forget to check it off.
Fantastic sponsor dollar shave club link to below.
Thank you for watching.